Daniel Jeremiah here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you DJ I'm doing great rich
I just want to know if with Mike not
being there will still have the same
assortment of snacks and goodies up
there as well may och was and this is
this is I don't think it's ever been put
on the air he was addicted to Mike and
Ikes so are you are you are you a Mike
and Ike person as well DJ you know what
I actually would be more of a gentleman
guy and that'll open up so many avenues
for a Seinfeld conversation so I think
that's the way we're going to go
refreshing by the way that would be the
first Seinfeld conversation I ever have
in that booth because if it wasn't
stripes or if it wasn't Sugar Hill Gang
Mayock did not understand it as you know
DJ played a hit though he did I look
forward to by the way I just look
forward to all of it and I guess we can
have our first draft conversation right
now and I'm sure we're gonna have it and
it might not have much more clarity
between now and the time that Kyle
Amar'e looks like he's going to be at
the combine so let's just start with
this is Carla Marie first-round draft
pick worthy for a kid that may or may
not or we're expected to hear his name
thrown into the NFL Draft ring is an
eligible player by this weekend well
look if you went back five years ago and
asked me if a five foot nine quarterback
would not only would get drafted would
be you know would be probably a stretch
a first-round pick you know you people
were just it was been laughter but it's
different it's different right now and
the way the league is gone and with his
unique skill set absolutely I think
somebody will do it he's not for
everybody there's gonna be some people
that'll have to have an issue with the
height more than anything else but he is
he was electric in terms of his
athleticism and arm strength his aren't
sense is off the charts
we've seen with Baker Mayfield just how
strong his arm was we know it was
Goodrich but it's it's he's got one of
the better arms in the NFL this kid is
every bit the same arm strength now the
difference is the reason why I would
take her he's not Baker Mayfield he's
not as
just the pinpoint accuracy that we've
seen from Baker Mayfield at Oklahoma and
we saw it in the NFL this this is not
the same level of accuracy and don't
don't send me the completion percentage
and all that because that has nothing to
do it I'm just talking about ball
placement that's Ruiz a little bit off
but yeah he's somebody will do it
absolutely somebody will do it so
someone will do it
what about Arizona being one to do it
I'm sure you saw that video that's
clanking around from the end of October
when at the time Texas Tech head coach
Kliff Kingsbury talking up Carla Murray
saying I would take him with the first
overall pick if I could and now look who
really can do that Daniel what do you
think I'd be shocked if it happened a
couple different thoughts number one if
if they were fully believed in Kliff
Kingsbury and really went all in with
Kliff Kingsbury don't you think that
they would give him the freedom to hire
everybody that he wants to hire now you
can hear that that's being run a little
bit from the front office I've attempted
leaning on the front office in terms of
who they're going to bring in as
assistant coaches but yet now you're
going to give him you give him the veto
power to say out with Josh rose and
we're going to bring in my guy that's
given an awful lot of power to Kliff
Kingsbury I just don't see that
happening but the other side of it is we
got to know Josh through the draft
process I got to know him a little bit
don't they need to come out in the next
24 hours and refute this I mean because
chapters yep there's a big name and I
know he was just kind of floating it out
there but he's he is a he is a very
respected name and for that thought to
even be out there in the universe if I'm
Josh Rosen I'm sitting here saying they
better come out the next 24 hours and
say josh is our guy or I'm gonna be
pretty upset I don't blame you DJ at all
and you're referring to what Adam said
on on ESPN this morning saying that he
thought it was not out of the realm or
these are the you know quarterbacks or
commodities the way that he put it
Kliff Kingsbury was on good morning
football today and didn't flat-out come
out and say yeah josh is our guy he we
did talk him up about all of his
abilities I don't think I'm missing
anything here DJ
yeah no I to me it's just is what my
that's floating out there I don't think
that's going to be that's gonna make for
an interesting launch to the Josh Rosen
Kliff Kingsbury release if they don't
come out there and say look this is we
took this kid in the first round last
year we totally believe in his ability
and and we're moving forward to have any
thoughts at the you know to the contrary
is crazy and our focus is on with this
first pick whether we select here
whether we trade out is to surround Josh
Rosen with the support he needs for us
to win and then so while we're on the
subject of rookie quarterbacks and and
and new head coaches that are gonna be
attached to their hip and or veteran
quarterbacks that are attached to new
coaching hips Bruce Arians in Tampa
Kliff Kingsbury in Arizona assumedly
with Josh Rosen Adam GaSe now with Sam
Bradford Matt Lafleur now with Aaron
Rodgers and I'm gonna just take Freddie
kitchens out of the mix right here
because obviously he's been with Baker
and we've seen what it looks like which
one do you think has the best
opportunity to succeed in in in the
manner in which management envisions it
through the interview process I actually
think the foreign Rodgers is going to be
the best marriage he's gonna run
it's that Shanahan scheme is run you
know what you take throw out what you
saw in Tennessee because they just kind
of had to do what they had to do there
but that is a that is you know it's
joked about the connection to Sean
McVeigh well Sean McVeigh comes from
Shanahan Street and think about the year
that Matt Ryan had under Kyle Shanahan
now take that same same offensive
approach and put Aaron Rodgers in the
role of Matt Ryan I mean I don't see how
Aaron Rodgers doesn't just post
ridiculous numbers in that system so I
think that is a really good marriage and
I actually think probably the second one
I don't know if you could have found a
better spot or a better human being to
pair with Jameis Winston than what
they're able to find in Bruce Arians he
is like the perfect guy to get out of
Jameis Winston what you need to get out
of him was just enough of simple Fisher
I mean think about tennis stylistically
Jimbo Fisher's personality and kind of
this
that Jimbo Fisher has that's ba I mean
that's what that's what Aryans brings to
the table I think he's gonna infuse
Jewish went there with a lot of
confidence is gonna he's gonna believe
him and I think we'll see the best of
Jameis Winston I really do now obviously
I meant Sam darn 'old not Sam Bradford
that would be a heck of a pairing for
the Jets right now gays and darn it
what do you think of the gays hire
Peyton Manning pound the table for for
him as a quarterback whisper for Ford
Arnold what do you think of that pairing
I think it's good I'm gonna you know I'm
always on on Sam Donald I was before the
draft last year I thought once he came
back from read you watch that team as
close as any I thought you got a glimpse
of what he can be he's he's a special
special talent so you know gates I think
is gonna be able to get it out of him
their biggest thing again as you know
rich they've got to get some people
around him so that it's not going to
matter who's coaching that team unless
they go out get some help up front and
get him some more help to throw the
football to so I think that's got a
chance to really work Adam GaSe has been
he's gotten a lot out of Peyton Manning
he got a lot of it G Cutler early on
down there in Miami he had Tannehill
playing really well and then injuries
just kind of beset that team I mean I
kind of throw out the season last year
for the Dolphins that they weren't very
good to start with and then all the
injuries just kind of crushed them
Daniel Jeremiah here on the Rich Eisen
show all right let's remove your NFL
Network former scout draft analysts hat
and put on the the lid that you wear
with Matt money Smith in the local radio
booth for the Los Angeles chargers
seeing the Chargers as you have the
matchup that you like on behalf of the
Chargers going in New England is what I
think they match up extremely well with
the Patriots and when you look kind of
across the board you know that the
challenge is going to be the Patriots
going to come out and try and jam it
down our throats but if they can get in
pass rush situations with Tom Brady and
what they've proven what they can do
with Bosa and Ingram sliding in and they
have Chenin to osoo outside and Issac
Rochelle
all right they're situated we you go
back to the Super Bowls that they
struggle with you know the games with
with the Giants to me inside pressure is
what gets the Patriots and I think to
what the Chargers have done with Gus
Bradley kicking those two guys inside I
think those are matchups and heavily
favored the Chargers they just they got
to get the third down so you know they
got to find a way whether or not they're
going to play the four Safety's again or
whether they throw some linebackers out
there they've got to find a way to get
the Patriots and third and five plus if
they do I really like the Chargers
matchups there and then on the other
side of the ball you know rivers people
have kind of crushed rivers that hadn't
played his best ball coming down the
stretch rich but man the defense is with
the two games in Baltimore and in the
past rust for the Broncos and that
that's what kind of gave him fits I
don't think the patient's are going to
be able to generate that type of heat on
Phillip Rivers and I think they'll have
some opportunities down the field Steven
Naismith just told me hunter Henry's
active for this game Daniel I know he's
been terrific and so in all seriousness
what do you think he can bring to the
table Sunday well well the biggest thing
is speed you know he just he runs so
much better than what they have right
now with with Antonio Gates and Virgil
green and Bertrille greens been kind of
an unsung hero with what the job he does
in the run game he's outstanding as a
blocker Antonio's playing his best
football in terms of getting open and
making plays down the stretch but
neither those guys are really going to
be able to stretch the seam and and
really really run and stretch things out
Hunter Henry can give you that now I
don't know how much he's going to play
if it's five plays ten plays 20 plays I
know both so when he was coming off that
long layoff they kind of targeted 20
plays and I think he ended up playing 32
plays in that first game so you know
what target is and I think that'll be
adjusted based on how he feels but I I'm
anticipating maybe about 20 snaps well
the charges of one games in four
different time zones and the only game
that they've lost outside of their home
stadium is here in Los Angeles DJ that
said it looks like high twenty-nine low
17 coldest game of the year for the
Chargers that affects them how do you
think
you know we've been fortunate all year I
mean this is this is a team that went to
London and got good weather I think it
rained when you came but week asked her
but it was nice weather in London nice
weather and Cleveland nice weather in
candy city in Pittsburgh and saddle it
didn't rain I mean they just had just
luck all over the place with weather
yeah cold is fine I think as long as
it's not really wet I don't think that's
a big of an impact I think they'll be ok
with the weather ok and self Scout the
Chargers can be beaten by the Patriots
how what do you think Anthony Lynn and
that staff Whisenhunt Gus Bradley are
huddled up thinking about right now no
to me it's all this game is gonna be won
or lost based off what the Patriots
doing the red zone the Patriots are a
death by a million paper cuts offense
run run underneath rose I don't think
the balls messy all over the Chargers
head which pushes which pushes all the
importance on can you get stops in the
red zone if Tom Brady can get Gronk
going down there in the red zone and
their score and touchdown instead of
field goals the Patriots will win
charges have been pretty good in the red
zone that'll need to continue if they're
gonna sneak out of there with the win ok
the other games this weekend that's our
poll question right Chris today yeah we
haven't asked it yet ask it of Daniel
Jeremiah go for ya DJ who has the best
chance of an upset this weekend Chargers
Colts Cowboys e which road teams got the
best divisional chance do you think I'll
work backwards I'll say the Eagles have
the biggest challenge that's gonna be a
tough one I don't think they can pull
that one off I think it would be between
you two the Cowboys or the Colts and I
would say I'll probably say the Cowboys
would have the best shot just again
styles make fights and I think their
defense can get matched up pretty well
with this Rams awesome yeah you took the
Chargers out of the equation there what
do you mean by styles make fights for
that game Cowboys at Rams well to me I
just think with what the Rams are able
to do to so many teams and get to the
perimeter they can get to the perimeter
with with Gurley in the run game they
can get the perimeter with those fly
sweeps the ball gets out and they stress
you to be able to run inside out and the
Cowboys are equipped to do that with
those two linebackers with with Smith
and band rush they fly to the perimeter
so I think that that works in their
favor and what works in the Colts favor
do you think that's gonna be a shootout
I mean I don't know and have a hot tape
there but I mean I
I just had to look at that I think both
these teams are gonna score a bunch
I think the Colts have a legit shot just
because they're working against a
defense that's a little more vulnerable
but then the other side of it you've got
haven't been around coach Reid with an
extra week those numbers are pretty darn
impressive so that's a pick'em that's a
pick'em to me but it's uh we don't we
don't do the gambling thing but lots of
points well I'd be remiss if I'd if I
let you go without asking you our poll
question that we asked coming off of the
national championship game just to mix
again College in the pros we asked this
poll question DJ and I'd love to get
your thoughts on it if you had to buy a
stock and a quarterback over the next 10
years your choices are Trevor Lawrence
to a taco viola or any of the drafted
quarterbacks in this past year's draft
class in 2018 you would choose which
answer oh well I'm gonna be true then
I'll get grief for it but I'm gonna
stick to my guns and I'm gonna says
that's I just I really believe in Sam
Donnell he's young man he is really
young but I haven't seen I saw that
Trevor Lawrence up at a high school camp
but but the the opening up and - two
years ago up in Oregon and he is pretty
special now I mean he is he is he is
really good so I'd like to I'd like to
be able to split my stock if I could is
my one by one is that beautiful slowing
me down there question all right I gotta
just ask one more time here I mean what
why'd Arnold I mean what what have you
seen certainly from this past year we
saw that that opening night and Monday
Night Football when it was so insane how
well he was playing you texted me or
called me because you wanted to get a
contact high from a jet fan that was one
of my favorite calls of the entire
playing season DJ but we also saw that
he got banged up he did come back in and
and make some very nice throws in some
difficult spots and some games that
didn't really mean anything in the
standings what do you see for the future
out of him then right I think the thing
that would get me most excited about Sam
Donald was look what that offense looked
like without him
I mean they have had nothing and he made
them competitive he's mentally and
physically tough I don't think anybody
can dispute that watching him if you
watched him this this year he can make
every throw
and then his improvisational skills I
think are what set him apart and make
him pretty special now the challenges
with mike McKagan and they got to go
good some help
but I believe in him I believe in him in
a big way all right DJ safe travels to
New England and back and we'll chat down
the line we'll chat down a lot about a
Chargers team that has just been looking
terrific last thing Richard yeah I just
I heard I know I think it was a TV
rejoined but you were listening to he
was listening off your Adam's head
linesman
yes I wrote down two 90s references
after a big win gates in your face then
also after a big Sam darn old game we
could play a little ace of gates is a
great back page headline ace of case is
really something we need to just put a
pin in that one that's fantastic good
job DJ thanks for the call
but you got it ace of case the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience